החשיבות של quantum computing היא גם מוערכת בחסר
וגם מוגזמת בו-זמנית.
למרות שהיא לא תחליף מחשבים קונבנציונליים
חדשנות קוונטית מייצגת פרדיגמת מחשוב חדשה.
מחשבים קוונטיים יכולים לעבוד בשיתוף עם מחשוב נוכחי
תשתית לפתרון בעיות מורכבות שבעבר
נחשבו לבלתי מעשיות או בלתי אפשריות.
זה יכול להיות משנה פרדיגמה.
למשל הקושי לפרק מספרים גדולים
לגורמים ראשוניים הוא הבסיס של
קריפטוגרפיה מודרנית. עבור גודל המספרים שמשתמשים בהם במפתח ציבורי
פרטי מודרני הצפנה החישוב הזה ייקח
למחשב הקונבנציונלי המהיר ביותר מעל 300 טריליון שנים.
למחשב קוונטי בקנה מידה גדול שעובד
עם האלגוריתם של Shor החישוב הזה יכול לקחת שניות.
בעיות מורכבות כאלה קיימות בכל התעשיות.
היישומים הפוטנציאליים של quantum computing
הם עצומים.
מחשבים קוונטיים כבר גדלים
ונעשים מסוגלים יותר,
כשאנחנו שואפים להתמודד עם בעיות מורכבות יותר.
מאז 2016, IBM הפכה מחשבים קוונטיים לנגישים
לציבור דרך אתר עם ממשק גרפי שנראה כמו תו מוזיקלי
שנראה כמו תו מוזיקלי.
וערכת פיתוח התוכנה Qiskit
שמאפשרת למשתמשים לתכנת מחשבים קוונטיים.
מדענים בתוך ומחוץ לעולם הארגוני
מריצים ניסויים
דרך פורטלים דומים. הם חוקרים גישות לכימיה
ובעיות למידת מכונה ומנסים להבין
אילו סוגי שאלות הם יכולים לשאול
ואיך הם ינסחו את השאלות האלה
כשהטכנולוגיה תתקדם עוד. עכשיו זה
הזמן הנכון למנהלי עסקים להתכונן
ל-quantum. התנאים נמצאים במקום לניסוי
והרחבה של הטכנולוגיה החדשה מהותית הזאת.
ארגונים שמבקשים להיות בחזית
של המהפך הטרנספורמציוני הזה
יתפסו יתרון תחרותי. ההכשרה הזאת
תכין אותך להתחיל את מסע ה-quantum שלך!